before we go as promised eleven-year-old
journalist Jaden Jefferson with us to
share his own report Jaden what do you
have for us my story's about a new
underwater memorial to honor military
veterans the circle of Heroes open this
week off the Gulf Coast of Florida it's
it's 40 feet underwater at the bottom of
the sea
12 life-size statues represent the men
and women in uniform Sean Campbell
served as a combat medic in Iraq he did
he dived down to see the memorial
Campbell was surprised to find his own
name on one of the statues 12 more
statues will be installed next year they
will complete this 100 foot circle Wow
amazing tell us what's the secret to
being a great journalist I would
definitely say it takes practice and I
mean a lot of practice a lot of practice
goes into it I would definitely say in
definitely I'll get in make sure the
facts are straight and really
double-checking really goes into it
sound check double checking fat checking
and it seems like you've got your hands
in everything you know how to edit you
know how to shoot you said you love
outlook oh yes outlook I mean outlook is
easy and organized for me I mean when I
print out a script or something fine we
go Jurina for Dana for Jaden Jefferson
thanks for being with us see you
tomorrow on CBS this morning bye-bye